(audience cheering)
Please welcome back to our show, Laura Benanti.
(audience cheering wildly)
Oh my God.
Thank you
Laura, you're so incredible in so many things that you do
and this is really no exception.
You are unrecognizable,
Thank you.
physically.
Yeah.
I mean, you look at you.
I don't know who was like, oh yeah, Laura Benanti,
she can play Amy Schumer's mother.
You look, how?
How did you do it?
Amy.
I mean, Amy and I did a play on Broadway together
called "Meteor Shower" that Steve Martin wrote,
Of course.
And we became,
(Laura laughing)
Sorry, Steve Martin, eek!
I know. Same, same.
That was me every day in rehearsal.
Just like,
(Laura panting)
But yeah, so we did, we became friends that way.
And then she just saw, I think, a quality in me
where she felt like you can do this and we'll figure it out.
We'll put a wig on you.
We'll give you prosthetics,
at least in the first episode where I'm an older woman
and then all of the other subsequent episodes
I'm in flashback.
But yeah, she saw, you just need a person to be like,
I see you, and then,
Yeah.
you're good.
That's so true.
Was she,
(audience clapping)
For real.
What is Amy Schumer like as a director?
She's incredible.
She's able to be like,
okay, this is how you hear something best.
This is how you hear something best.
And then she just frames it in such a way
that you feel like you came up with it yourself.
Well, this show is gaining so much steam
and for all the right reasons.
It is incredibly introspective.
It is beautiful. It is haunting.
And it's just fantastically acted.
It's so good.
Yay. I'm so glad you like it.
(audience clapping)
It's so good.
Thank you.
I'm so glad you like it.
Well, we're here at the desk, Laura.
Yeah.
You wanna hear some headlines?
I really do.
ITV News reports Portland, Oregon,
just got it's first sports bar for women.
(audience cheering)
Wow.
Yay.
I love it so much.
I love the name of the bar.
Me too.
Right?
It's called "The Sports Bra",
(Ross laughing)
a genius name, thought up by owner Jenny Nguyen,
a former college basketball player herself.
The walls are decked out with the jerseys
of incredible female athletes.
The bar menu is sourced from women-owned businesses
and on the TVs, only women's sports.
Only women.
So full on.
(audience cheering)
I love it.
The Sports Bra might be the first women's sports bar
on the planet.
I wanna go there now.
I'm glad to know it exists.
Right?
It makes me happy.
It's just so fantastic.
Yeah, I know it's gonna be a success
because I heard about it and thought,
that doesn't already exist?
I know.
And when you can lock into something that duh,
should be a thing, that's when it takes over the world.
So watch out, The Sports Bra's coming to a town
near you, I bet.
Yeah.
I bet, hashtag franchising.
(audience clapping)
Thank you.
Exactly, exactly.
Well, up next, what about this story?
A very important subject everybody,
what is your pet's name and what does it say about you?
Study Finds reports people are judging you
for your pet's name.
Really?
A new survey found six out of ten people say
they'll actually judge you for what you named your pet.
And I kind of get this because if I meet you,
and you're like, oh, this is my cat Fluffy,
I'm like, eye roll, next.
Okay. Good to know.
Okay.
Your pet, I think I'm one of the people that judge.
Your pet's name should be interesting, don't you think?
Well, my pet's names are,
they're two little rescues and Petey Pie and Lily.
Oh, that's my daughter.
Cute!
That's my daughter, Ella,
and my super amazing husband, Patrick.
He holds Petey Pie like a baby.
Because she had to have surgery when we got her,
she was so abused, they both were.
And we really nursed them back to health,
especially my husband.
Oh my God.
So Petey Pie and Lily Rose.
(audience clapping)
Where does Petey Pie come from?
So Bernadette Peters,
Yeah, the great Bernadette Peters,
An icon, yes.
She works with so many shelters,
and she recommended One Love For Animals,
which is the organization that we went to
to rescue Petey Pie.
Petey Pie.
So Petey Pie, so she was named Sweetiepie
when we first got her,
and I was like Petey Pie for Bernadette Peters.
That's perfect.
That's so cute. See?
Ross, what are your dogs names again?
Well, I have,
Well, you have three.
I have three rescues, there they are.
Yay.
So the closest one,
Oh my God.
is Audrey,
for like Audrey Hepburn,
Oh yes.
cause she has bold eyebrows.
She does.
The second one is Selena,
after Selena, the singer, "Bidy Bidy Bom Bom".
Oh, yeah.
because she's curvy.
And then Pa Earl in the back is named after my great grandpa
cause I adopted him at 12,
and that was like the oldest name I could think of.
Wait-
Oh, I love that.
And you have, what are your dogs named?
Douglas,
Douglas and Lucy.
Cute names.
Aw, I love those names.
That's Douglas on the right,
and that's Lucy on the left.
Aw.
All right. So start judging everyone.
(everyone laughing)
Laura Benanti, you are so amazing.
"Life & Beth" is no exception.
It's on Hulu right now.
Everybody's talking about it for a very good reason.
Please watch it. It is phenomenal.
(audience clapping)
(upbeat music)